okay let's go next to our caller from
the 206 area code who's calling today
from 206 David yes hey David I'm Jesse
I'm from the Seattle area hey Jesse
what's going on so I you know I just
recently gone on Twitter and I noticed
I'm curious do you think that to listen
to progressive media kind of in a bubble
because I've noticed that a lot of
people actually really really do this
like Bernie Sanders so for a lot of you
saying you're seeing tweets from Omo who
don't like Bernie yeah but it's pretty
widespread in that sense is it
widespread it like a lot of the big
lefties on Twitter are very very anti
Bernie Sanders like who and not anyone
in this establishment just people who
are very popular and put it for harping
on Donald Trump or whatever so like who
would be in had ample of that there's a
Twitter account called the resistance or
something like that right there anybody
work yeah and I get into these big
Twitter wars and a lot of times I
noticed that a lot of people from the
left sound exactly like Donald Trump
supporters and they pair it like fox
news media coverage on Bernie Sanders
like what would be an example of a
crisis narrative on Bernie that the Left
Peretz the other day I got into an
argument with someone and they were
saying you know I said look at Bernie
Sanders past with his comments on all
the major issues they haven't changed at
all and people say things like well you
know Biden's better because he shows
that he can change and things like that
and also that's not unique to Bernie
that that's a really old that that's a
talking point in order to be able to
take both sides of flip-flops and either
way defend your candidate here's the
Twitter is not the real world okay I am
going to base my assessment of how
favorably people look at Bernie not
based on my personal interactions on
Twitter I'm going to look at actual
properly sampled favorability polls and
that that's what I would be looking at
and Bernie is you know mildly popular in
the context of politicians who mostly
are not like the most liked people and a
huge partisan divide so I would go by
that I'm not gonna I wouldn't go by my
personal interactions on Twitter and by
the way if I were you I'd probably stop
even getting into those arguments on
Twitter it's it's just depressing and
stressful it's a waste of time yeah I
can agree with that kind of talk
yeah good all right very good appreciate
the phone call great to hear from you
and on that note I will go to a break
and I will take calls again sorry for
everyone that I was not able to get to
today